So, what was interesting was number 1, shared economics.
Well, that was right. You both have an economic reason to want a partner.
But you know what?
Number 2 is right as well, economies of scale.
You partnering with a much larger company
means you could take advantage of their supply chain
or their volume discounts or the massive sales force they have.
But you know, number 3 is right as well.
Large companies, just by definition because they're larger,
have more of everything than you do.
Wouldn't it be great if you could get your hands on some of it somehow?
And number 4. Access to customers.
Well, we have 3 million customers, and today you have 3.
That's a good idea too.
Finally, access to their marketing or their brand.
Wouldn't it be great to have the General Electric label
or the Intel label or be a Facebook partner next to yours?
And so the answer is: they all apply.